donc l'agent de matt peu d'air
elle était attendue celle là et c'est
avant tout le reste de la france que les
habitants de nancy de plus de 75 ans ont
pu se faire vacciner dès ce matin où
j'attendais ça avec impatience
j'avais peur de d'abord le virus donc
c'est la seule chaîne seul moyen
d'éviter parce que je vais encore vivre
un peu l'espoir de vivre surtout plus
normalement
nos petits-enfants ou manque c'est le
moteur de notre vie à notre âge voilà
dans le centre des congrès transformée
pour l'occasion le vaccin conserver au
frigo sous clé si la ville de nancy
arrive première en france c'est beaucoup
grâce à la pression des élus locaux qui
ont bousculé le gouvernement il son
calendrier prudent diront certains trop
lent diront d'autres
c'est une vraie course contre la montre
que nous avons engagées avec le virus
avec la conduite 19 et nous voulons la
gagner cette course parce que nous
sommes un territoire ici et dans le
grand nancy dans le grand est en france
particulièrement touchée
cela fait plusieurs semaines plusieurs
mois même que le virus circule à un
niveau élevé bien plus élevé que la
moyenne nationale que les lits à
l'hôpital sont particulièrement saturé
par des malades de la queue vite que ce
soit en médecine ou en réanimation une
course contre la montre peut-être mais
tous les français ne sont pas prêts à
prendre la ligne de départ selon les
dernières enquêtes d'opinion
c'est encore aujourd'hui plus de 40%
d'entre eux qui se montre méfiance sinon
carrément hostiles au vaccin contre la
coved la patrie de louis pasteur est
devenue championne mondiale du
scepticisme vaccinale et le vaccin
contre la coved n'échappe pas à cette
logique perte de confiance envers les
autorités scandales médicaux du passé et
une perception négative de l'industrie
pharmaceutique
ce sont autant de facteurs qui
alimentent cette méfiance record dans
les pays développés en ce moment il ya
plus de personnes en france qui veulent
se vacciner rapport au nombre de vaccins
je laisse passer à l'est est prioritaire
et ça ne me dérange pas bien au
contraire
moi je le fais pas parce que je fais
déjà pas le vaccin de la grippe
donc je prends pas le risque de faire le
vaccin du coc vide
je n'ai pas confiance notre team s'est
pas forcément du 100% mais nos types
c'est de vacciner et de convaincre les
hésitants et en leur montrant que ça
marche qui a pas d'effets secondaires et
que ça a un impact sur l'épidémie on
amènera ses hésitant à la vaccination
des hésitants comme anne une infirmière
à la retraite qui s'est finalement
décidée au dernier moment
au début j'étais un peu quand même je
pendrai d'autres se fassent vacciner
on va chercher des cathos au peu
l'hécatombe
elle menace plutôt dans les nouveaux cas
de co vide qui sont en pleine ascension
en france
marie ève bédard radio-canada nancy en
lorraine